die kommt doch auch direkt herzlich
willkommen zu einem was mache ich heute
ich hab euch bei twitter gesagt dass ihr
mir ich habe danach nicht bekomme ich
weiß ich weiß ich und vermissten
hier solltet mir irgendwelche
bescheuerten videos zu senden das habt
ihr auch zahlreiche
macht eigentlich noch mal irgendwas
anderes
ich muss dich ich wusste dass es kommt
immer wieder ihr seid so willst du so
gemein ist wenn du hast die aufgabe
tomatensaft zu integrieren in die
deutsche youtube szene die trainer hätte
es noch auf meine nachbarn kommen ich
glaube ich voll okay mir ist aufgefallen
dass man die tür gar nicht schließen
konnte
falls ihr ständig camps dallas dieser
kerl wie tomaten erinnert diese ganze
scheiße mit tomatensaft ins leben
gerufen und ich weiß auch kann ich
machen das umfeld wenn ich hier
draufschlagen anfängt samstagmittag luca
hat auf seinem tisch um zu schauen ob
die kamera umfeld hey nachbarn gegenteil
ich glaube die haben halt
geschlechtsverkehr kommen wir weiter zum
nächsten video was mir ein gesendet
wurde war wirklich bei allem respekt
seine taschentücher packung zu filmen
und mir zu schicken das ist auf jeden
fall eine richtig harte einsatz
nein bitte bitte tut das nicht immer
sind diese momente taschentücher packung
youssif oktober richtig trat wenn man
einfach mal auf die strasse guckt sieht
man dass die straße dort wirklich in
einem top zustand vorhanden ist ich weiß
ja nicht wo ihr wohnt aber vielleicht
sollte die straße neu asphaltiert werden
ich sie mir
dpa
falls ihr euch fragt ob ich die musik
dahinter gelegt haben ein
die musik hat sie wirklich selber
dahinter gelegt hatten dieses video
geschickt welche rollen der hätten wie
sie im bett aus ihrem skateboard vor dem
spiel
ich frag mich heute mittlerweile nichts
mehr mich würde es nicht wundern wenn
ich jetzt auch einmal richtige creepy
einsendungen bekommen würde
christoph daum herzinfarkt ich meine ich
verstehe es nicht ihr könnt ihr alle
kabel ganz vielleicht nächste mal nicht
unsichtbar sein auf einmal wieso sind
einwendungen habe ich immer so blöd ich
war ja gut hab ich bei twitter gesagt
dass sie mit tube videos werden soll ja
gut ist also weiter gesagt habt ihr
sollten wir einfach ein video schicken
kommt es diese einsamen kongressstadt
durchgesagt einfach im video sieht man
das mache ich jetzt auch
danke danke danke wirklich gibt also ja
ich poste nächstes mal einfach bei
twitter freunde schickt mir mein video
und ich möchte nur videos sehen wo ihr
sagt lokale wollten video hier hast du 1
wieso seid ihr noch dran
schaltet einfach geht main kanal ist
wenn man meinen kanal mit einem
gegenstand vergleichen würde wäre es
diesen müll main kanal ist müll gegen
diese dieses schicken luca videos einen
videos auf meinem kamera immer also
einerseits natürlich komplett niveaulos
aber andererseits auch immer dass ich
nur was gegen main kanal sagen
warum
warum tue ich mir das an jetzt guckt
mich dieser spaß hier auch noch die
ganze zeit an mit seiner ich habe gerade
obst fresse ich meine wenn die
einsendungen wenigstens so wären wie bei
wetten dass soja luca guck mal ich kann
mir meinen namen kurzen oder so ich
vergessen kriege ich mit einem damals
auf jeden fall irgendwas nicht in
ordnung oder magen leber herz ihre wohl
kommen kommen wir nun zu einer 1 sendung
die ich eigentlich feiern weil es pizza
beinhaltet
bin ich wirklich so dumme meinen videos
hab grad kapuze aufgesetzt weil ich
dachte damals veddeler damm ich dachte
sie aber ich glaube ich bin nicht so
cool wer macht sich die arbeit und
schneidet zu einen crêpe zusammen in
pizza und dann irgendwas jedes mal wie
gericht jetzt habt ihr wieder material
dafür nicht passe sogar in dieser folge
extra auf das nicht zu den lucky nato
kommen kann was ich in die kamera zeigt
ich habe glaub ich sogar noch nicht in
die kamera gezeigt was ihnen schon kennt
oder nicht beim akinator ist sogar
meinen müll ist sogar schon beim
akinator kommen wir nun zur nächsten
sendung
vor die kamera es ist ein eigenes video
ist ein anderer ist gut ich weiß ich
weiß ich will es mir aber nicht geben es
ist einfach geil
sie kommt doch auch ein halbes haus
gehört bei der nächsten sendung geht es
mal wieder um essen nur deswegen habe
ich mit reingenommen ich kriege ich die
krise
also was ich auf was für ideen ihr kommt
wer füllt so was mit reis anstellen da
es kommt mir nicht so akzeptiert was
gesagt reiß hektisch ich dachte es wäre
witzig ich weiß dass es das nicht war
eigentlich ist das seien halt wie viele
erkenntnisse ich mal selber meinen
videos sammeln kann eine scheiße crêpes
dumm behindert die abonniert vielleicht
kann er die letzte einfach nur noch mal
so ein bisschen die wohl die folge
reinbringen
ich wollte mir nicht sagen wollte ich
aus mir wird schlecht aus so schön raus
ist mache nicht zu fernen sie mir
unnötig